hey there I thought that I would take a
moment just to answer some of the most
common questions that I get on LinkedIn
so let's Jump Right In uh Steve T asks
how do you repair a broken work culture
where you are not the one at the top
this may be the most common question I
get which is how to have a positive
impact on the organization you work for
when you aren't in a position of formal
Authority the answer is be the leader
you wish you had the answer is work to
have impact in the sphere of influence
you can you may not be able to impact
the whole organization but you can have
impact on the people with whom you work
those to the side of you those who may
uh be below you in the hierarchy and
believe it or not even those above you
in the hierarchy they're human beings
too so um all the things that you've
been studying about what it takes to be
a great leader empathy listening all of
these good things you do it and what
ends up happening is these these little
bubbles form of magic and then somebody
moves and goes to another group and then
they take everything they've learned all
the positivity and Joy from that little
group and they start to bring it over
there and before you know it the ripples
spread now you had to have you have to
have a bit of an infinite mindset
because depending on the size of the
organization it can take more time than
youd expect but believe it or not you
could have a very very positive impact
in an organization without being the
person in charge i' seen it happen many
times the tail can Wag the Dog so be the
leader you wish you had okay um I have a
question here from Jasmine um how do you
find the right balance between having a
leadership style that is more soft
friendly and motivating and about
building meaningful relationships than
having to have hard conversations and
set firm expectations with your team
well Jasmine I got some good news and
bad news the good news is I love that
you're that kind of leader the hard news
is you're also going to have to learn
the skills to sometimes have difficult
conversations with members of your team
and hold them accountable I've seen it
happen many many times where somebody's
a good leader a kind leader sweet
motivating all those things but without
the ability to hold people accountable
have difficult conversations or give
difficult feedback what starts to happen
is the team starts to be sort of like a
hippie commune where everybody gets
along but nothing really gets done and
deadlines start to flip uh Slide by and
there's no mechanism to hold people
accountable think about your think about
children like we want our kids to be
happy and we want our kids to be joyous
but at the same time they have to eat
their vegetables they got to clean their
bedrooms right there there are
mechanisms of accountability so as you
go on your leadership Journey you have
to learn how to do these things you're
just going to have to likewise if
somebody were really good at hard
conversations and really good at
accountability but not so good at the
more human stuff that you're good at
they're going to have to learn those
skills too you want to be a complete
leader Hayes asks if you could be a
superhero which one would you want to be
you know over the years I have to be
honest I've gone through different ones
when I was younger I wanted to be the
flash I think that's cuz I was a fast
runner as a little kid and sort of went
well you know I kind of went through a
Batman phase cuz he's just a normal
human being I mean normal mean he wasn't
born with any superpowers or comes from
another planet he's just a guy with a
gadget and I kind kind of like that um
then there's always Spider-Man cuz I
mean it's Spider-Man um but I guess I
don't know what phase am I going through
right
now I'm sort of in a Batman Spider-Man
kind of phase yeah yeah I'll stick with
that Lana asks storytelling is a
powerful skill what's your favorite tip
for crafting a compelling and memorable
story okay top tip how to tell a
compelling story speak it as if it's a
movie so when I'd like to tell a story I
like to give more detail Than People
expect I wouldn't just say so this guy
walks into a bar and he's talking to the
bartender i' say it's like a dark and
stormy night and this guy he's been like
you know walking for Miles he's
exhausted it comes across a bar and it's
one of those oldfashioned bars where
like the wood is old rickety and it's
like the neon sign say Miller Light and
I'm painting a picture of something that
I may have seen or maybe really did
actually happen that other people can
put themselves eles in my story in other
words I want it to be like a movie for
them so top tip for telling a good story
tell it as if it's a movie tell it if as
if you're trying to explain to somebody
what you experienced when you were there
even if there was a story about someone
else hope that helps Vicky C asks what's
next um great question Vicki I've
actually been in an intense sort of idea
searching mode um and not like sort of
in a lost sort of you know without my
glasses on the ground sort of way um I
have when I what happens is when I get
an idea for something I become sort of a
little bit obsessive with that idea and
I want to explore more and right now I'm
really sort of interested in concepts of
power if you look at some of the
challenges that business is facing our
society is facing our politics are
facing this sort of all these sorts of
power struggles um um we're seeing it
play out in all different ways and I'm
sort of really fascinated what it's like
to have power claim power feel like
you've lost it feel like you don't have
it what it means to find it all of these
things and how that affects not only the
organizations we work in but how it
affects our own well-being so whether it
becomes a book or a talk who knows stay
tuned but right now I'm going down the
rabbit hole of the research and I'm
finding it really fascinating over the
course of the next few months I'm sure
I'll dribble out some things um as I
have some insights CU I always like
sharing them getting your feedback dve M
asks uh what if anything keeps you up at
night um many things keep me up at night
I have one of those brains that never
shuts off so there are many sleepless
nights not cuz anything bad's going on
it's just cuz my my brain never shuts
down but um the things that uh often
keep me up at night are um I I'll replay
the events of the day or the week and if
there's a problem I haven't solved I'll
roll around with it the hard part is if
it keeps me up at night sometimes I have
to like convince myself you know deal
with this tomorrow um again it's not
always bad things but I I always sort of
I replay things um I'm in a constant
state of learning and Improvement um and
so I always I'm I'm always sort of d
double checking how I showed up in the
situation what could I have done better
you know am I happy with what I said am
I happy with how I performed um again
not under stressful way but always in a
state of C Improvement so that kept
sometimes keeps me up at night genevia
asks suicide is the biggest killer of
people aged 18 to 25 this deeply
troubles me recognizing a hopeful future
is vitally important for those who are
vulnerable uh how can the work of
optimism be used to facilitate hope and
promote Wellness thank you in advance
cons for considering my question jiv
have I share your concern and uh the way
I understand it one of the biggest
challenges we face um if you think about
sort of the roots of suicide the roots
of suicide come from loneliness they
come from feeling out of control um and
one of the best ways that we can guard
against those feelings is relationships
the quality of our relationships um I've
talked about it many times before like
yes phones are great social media is fun
but when it gets out of whack when we're
on on our phones we're out for dinner
with our friends when we're on our
phones we're sitting uh watching TV with
somebody um as opposed to having a
shared experience and the whole point is
about sharing experience Arthur Brooks
talks about this quite a lot which is
the difference between happiness and
enjoyment you can do something that
makes you happy pleasure pleasure he
talks about pleasure right they do mean
Pleasures you can do it by yourself um
yes wherever your imagination goes the
answ is yes all those kinds of Pleasures
that you can derive for social media
games whatever but enjoyment only
happens when you share the pleasure with
someone when you have a shared
experience when you actually engage with
somebody even if you're just sitting on
the couch watching TV with someone
you're with them not on your phone so
for me please please please please
please Foster your personal
relationships and one of the hardest
things and best things to do in in
fostering personal relationship is
calling someone when you are struggling
not just when you're having fun right
when you are in a bad place instead of
sitting by yourself call somebody and
say I am struggling will you I need your
help and giving someone the honor to sit
in mud with you and hold space with you
when you're struggling and to be able to
say to them I don't need need you to fix
anything right now can you just can you
just listen to me for a little bit
that's what I need that's what Fosters
real trust um we don't actually build
trust with people by offering help we
build trust by asking for it so I think
the best way we can protect ourselves
and our mental health is focus on
building personal
relationships um Eve asks um do you put
into practice all the great advice you
give the simple answer is I I really try
to um I don't get everything right
that's for sure I make bad decisions I
act badly say stupid things the same as
anybody else but what I try and work
really hard on is how I react after the
fact um um I do work really hard at all
the stuff all the stuff that I write
about I practice I start with why I
believe Leaders Eat Last and I maintain
an infinite mindset and all the
practices that are in there I do work
really hard to hold myself and my team
accountable and I have to serve as an
example um my team knows that I screw
things up and get things wrong but
they'll always see me take
accountability and try get things right
and practice what I preach so the simple
answer is yes it is a journey like
everybody else Bruce M asks if you have
crashed through illness uh or burnout at
a peak in your career how do you regain
your confidence to get back out there
without the fear of it happening again
great great great question so couple of
different answers number one is find
someone who's going through the same
thing as you believe it or not service
is one of the best ways to guard against
things happening again and to actually
help us improve the lot that we have
been dealt so find somebody who's going
through the same thing and take care of
them coach them work with them guide
them that's the amazing thing uh you
know Alcoholics Anonymous I've talked
about this before there's 12 steps to
beating the disease of alcoholism many
of us are familiar with the first step
admitting you have a disease admitting
you are an alcoholic but it's the 12th
step that is so significant Alcoholics
Anonymous knows that if you master the
first 11 steps but not the 12th you're
more likely to succumb to the disease
but if you master the 12th you're more
likely to beat it so what is the 12th
step service it's the it's the
requirement to help another alcoholic
that's what it is and so find someone
that you can go on the journey with by
helping them that's number one um the
other one is um is is accepting these
things I mean I've I've everything
you've talked about I've had I've
crashed I've got I've burnt out um I've
hit the bottom I've done all of these
things and the amazing thing is once
you've been there you just accept that
it happens and you survived and you're
okay and believe it or not just
accepting it builds a builds the
calluses builds the strength that you
made it through it once as much as you
don't want to go through it again you
can go through it again um usually I
think the fear that we get is fear of
the unknown and once it's known it's a
little less scary even if we don't want
it um that's what got me on my path with
start with why I hit rock bottom never
want to go through that again but I got
through it co none of us want to go
through some of the madness that we went
through at work with that but we got
through it we could have forced you know
that should build confidence anyway I
hope that helps uh please continue to
write in your questions because I really
love answering these um take care of
yourself take care of each
other